DUSTIN INGRAM: I'm Dustin
Ingram, developer advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
I'm really excited to announce
the general availability
of Python 3 Runtime on the App
Engine standard environment.
Python is one of the
most popular programming
languages and growing.
It's well suited for a
number of use cases including
web applications, machine
learning, and big data.
App Engine has
supported Python Runtime
from the very beginning,
more than 10 years now.
You may have tried Python
on App Engine in the past
and noticed that it was
very opinionated about what
you could and couldn't do.
This new Python Runtime
is very different.
Python 3.7 on App Engine is
our second generation Runtime.
That means it's based
on open source Python
from the Python
Software Foundation.
It supports Google
Cloud client libraries
for services like Cloud storage,
vision, translate, et cetera.
You can install
libraries, frameworks,
and other dependencies
using requirements.txt,
and best of all, Python 3.
I like to deploy web
apps to App Engine
because my app
scales automatically
up or down, even down to
zero, to meet incoming traffic
spikes.
I only need to think
about my Python code,
not the infrastructure or
wiring that runs my app.
And I only pay for
what my app uses,
and I can use App Engine's free
tier to easily try new things.
In this video, I'll
show you how to use
Flask, a popular and
versatile web framework,
to quickly write, deploy,
and test a Python 3 web
app on App Engine.
Once we've got the app deployed,
we'll iterate on it a bit
to take advantage of some
of those great new features.
There are three files
that will make up our app.
app.yaml, main.py,
and requirements.txt.
Let's start with app.yaml.
This file lets you
configure your app
in a number of different ways.
All we need to do in this
file is tell App Engine
that we want to use the
new Python 3.7 Runtime.
We do this by
adding these lines.
Next, moving down
our list of files,
let's define our app's behavior
by creating our main.py file.
This is where we can define the
core logic of our application.
We'll call it main.py
because that's
what App Engine uses
by default. But you
can call it whatever you want
as long as you configure it
appropriately.
We'll use Flask as
our web framework,
but you can use any
framework you'd like as well.
By default, App Engine
looks for a variable called
app inside your main.py file.
As you might guess, this
should correspond to your app.
We'll define an end point at
the root URL that just says
hello, world, and that's it.
Finally, the new Python
runtime understands
the same requirements
format that
is used by PIP and other
package installers and Runtimes
across the entire
Python ecosystem,
the requirements.txt file.
Because we've chosen Flask
as our web framework,
we'll specify it
as a dependency.
In a file called
requirements.txt,
we'll add Flask
and pin its version
to be exactly version 1.0.2, the
latest version that's currently
available.
Pinning the version
of a dependency
ensures that the next
time you deploy your app,
you won't install a newer
and possibly incompatible
version of your dependency,
which could lead to breakage.
So now we've defined
these three files--
app.yaml, main.py,
and requirements.txt.
Our app is finished.
Let's deploy it.
Deploying is easy with the
gcloud command line tool.
Once you've installed it
and authenticated yourself,
all you need to do is
type gcloud app deploy
to deploy your
app to App Engine.
Now that it's done, we
can type gcloud app browse
to view the app.
Looks great.
Now let's see what
else we can do.
Web apps are usually most useful
when they can accept input as
well as produce output.
What if we just want to say
hello to a specific person?
Let's see how we can
do this with Flask.
By importing the
request object, we
can inspect the query string
parameters from the URL.
We'll look for one called name.
Let's deploy that real quick
with gcloud app deploy.
If we don't pass any
parameters, it stays the same
and says hi to the whole world.
But if we add a name=Python3
parameter to the end
of the URL, we've now passed
that value into our app,
and it's rendered
as you would expect.
Since this is Python
3, we can make our code
even better by using f strings
instead of string concatenation
or by sticking a few emojis
right into our source code.
Putting the emoji in
line like that is great,
but what if we
wanted the user to be
able to include an emoji
of their own choice
by specifying it as text?
We could create a massive
mapping from emoji names
to their actual values
and find and replace them
in our name parameter.
Instead, let's use this
third party emoji package,
which is open source and
available on the Python Package
Index.
This package provides
an emojize function,
which will let us
turn text into emojis.
All we need to do is
add the dependency
to our requirements.txt
file like so.
Remember, always pin
your dependencies.
Now, in main.py, we can
import the emojize function
from the emoji library,
and then use it
to emojize the entire greeting.
Once again, we'll deploy
it with gcloud app deploy.
Now, let's add the
string colon snake
colon to our name
parameter and see what
it looks like in our browser.
Looks great.
So much more customizable.
So that's all there is
to making a Python 3
app that handles user
input and uses third party
libraries from PyPI.
Stay tuned for the
next episode, where
I'll show you how to deploy
a wag tail app to App Engine.
Feel free to ask questions
in the comments below.
And if you like
this video, please
subscribe to the GCP channel
for more videos like this.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]